hey everybody we're back with another
episode of
wild ride and i want to tell you that as
a guy
in the back half of my 40s who just
wants to beat up his body doing the
craziest stuff
possible i have so much love
for this week's guest david arquette the
guy's pushing 50 years old and he's in
there just
doing like heavy duty violent
backyard wrestling all kinds of
wrestling dude this is
such a crazy story and he's got this
documentary he sent me a screener i sent
him my gnarly documentary we both
watched each other's projects
that we got together to talk about it
man what a blast this was
ladies and gentlemen david arquette
yeah dude thanks bro what's up dude hey
what's up thanks for having me
and let me introduce my co-host scott
wow right off the bat right off the bat
up there we've got paul briskey what's
going on
and before we get started let's reassure
everybody that i have confirmed i have
the covid antibodies
so i cannot catch or spread coronavirus
is that how it works yeah it's like the
chicken pox is it really
yeah wow that's dope as long as you have
the antibodies the problem is that the
antibody your levels of antibodies like
go down and disappear so ultimately you
can get it again
but for now i've got them and i actually
successfully got into the red cross
uh convalescent plasma donation program
because i'm a hero with my i can help
people when do you go uh it dude i
couldn't get an appointment until like
august something or other but let's not
bore people with that
uh scott gets tested
i'm cool i i'll probably get tested
after this podcast
he does get tested every week yeah okay
so let's get into it
my god what a what a treat dude um we
follow each other on instagram and thank
thank you for that
uh where was it that we were uh on an
airplane together was that coming back
from the conor mcgregor fight
uh was it jet sweet it was dead sweet
coming home from vegas
it was in burbank but i'm not sure i
think it was somewhere random because i
was like why are you coming back from
somewhere random i don't know vegas i
think it was vegas it might have been
yeah it definitely was into the burbank
thing i don't think it was the jet sweep
thing though
that's the only trip we've ever taken
jetsuite on so
yeah right but in any case so
uh i i dm'd you not long ago
when i saw the first trailer for your
new documentary
you cannot kill david arquette and as
soon as i saw that trailer i was just
dying to watch it so i dm'd you like hey
man congrats on the dock
how do i see it and you said that the
chronovirus had [ __ ] it all up so
yeah we got into south by southwest and
then they
sort of every that got pushed everything
got pushed
so it's coming out soon it's coming out
at the end of august
is the is the actual uh
whatever distribution different because
of oh hell yeah everything's different
it's if it's in any theaters it'll be in
drive-ins but no regular seating so it
was going to be a theatrical release oh
yeah
dude sorry it so deserves it man it's so
deserved
oh thanks bro i loved your gnarly thank
you man
[Laughter]
i mean likewise dude and what a treat to
be able to uh
both talk about uh each other's
each other's uh you know things that we
that we just put out but um
now i had followed on you know i get my
news from tmz
i saw every time you were on there uh
you know like with the uh the wrestling
and it was just like wow
like david arquette is like how old are
you now
i'm 48 almost 49 okay i'm 46 now
so like we're in kind of the same boat
where we're way past the age
where we should be putting our bodies to
the test the way that we absolutely but
you're on another
[ __ ] level dude wow have you ever
like have you looked into have you like
done the
self work like why the [ __ ] am i doing
this kind of stuff
ah i think i think i have
and and for the most part i'm actually
in pretty good
physical condition uh yeah no no no it's
not that it's the
so i'm just equating it in the film
there's a death match i do
right oh my god we're completely
familiar with it yeah
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] and then just
exploring like why i would put myself
in that situation my wife's like do you
just want to die like should we have two
kids together
she was just [ __ ] pissed at me for
even doing it
let's let's work people up to them okay
okay yeah
because that's we just went right
here yeah i made a movie we definitely
have that
uh i mean that's such a notable scene
but the backdrop of this
documentary is that you had a movie
promotion back in the year 2000
for a movie called ready to rumble and
uh and
to promote that movie because it was a
movie about i presume wrestling yeah
and so to promote that movie you got
linked up with the
was it wcw yeah because they were owned
by warner brothers
so it's like they did a movie because
they had all these wrestlers
uh like on the thing when i read it i
was just a wrestling fan i was like this
is amazing it's like
me as a kid growing up and still loving
wrestling the way
i did when i was a little younger and
stuff right and so
that now of course the wcw was
subsequently purchased by wwe
later that's after next year when i came
into it w
wcw came in out of nowhere and a guy
named eric bischoff took him like
to be beating wwe
at the time so they were kind of going
back and forth they called it the monday
night wars
and it was like it was also like kind of
getting raunchy and crazy and they were
like trying to up each other you had
like evil hulk hogan yeah yeah the nwo
like yeah that whole thing happened yeah
and there and then uh
so when ready remember came out they had
already started losing to wwe and wwe
had now
stone cold and the rock and they were
kind of just taking off on a whole other
trajectory
so it was sort of like a you know
effort of just getting publicity for the
movie getting publicity for wcw
but they made me the champion right
wrestling
yeah they decided to promote your movie
they would actually have you win the
heavyweight
championship title in the wcw
and and if people don't remember the wcw
they'll certainly remember the the
personalities that were
in the mix at that time you were you
were you beat diamond dallas page
well sort of i love the way david
arquette tells stories like the one he's
about
to tell but i also love my cats
winnie and olivia now you know what's
crazy about the way i
keep their kitty litter their litter
boxes
are in my favorite rooms in the house
like my game room and it doesn't stink
at all that's why i get away with it
because i use the litter robot
which is the top rated
litter machine in the world because
these guys have been making them the
longest like
20 years here's how it works it senses
when the cat goes in
the cat does its business seven minutes
later it rotates
sips it drops all the waste into the
drawer
all i have to do is toss the bag
that's it plus the thing tells me when
to do it
because it's got an app that notifies me
on my phone
when the drawer is full it is so
easy and oh my god i'm so excited
that now i have a second little robot
in my other favorite room in the house
which is
the editing room dude
if you've got cats you have to have a
little robot
and so here's how you get one you go to
catpoop.com
and if you buy a litter robot right now
at catpoop.com you're gonna get a 90 day
money back guarantee because they're so
sure you're gonna love it
plus free shipping so again 90 day money
back guarantee and free shipping
if you go to catpoop.com right now
and buy yourself a litter robot yeah
dude
now let's hear this story it's kind of
weird because
i was buddies with him he's the the main
bad guy in the
ready to rumble movie i came in and
there's this
it was odd because it was a three-man
match or something
so it's it doesn't really make any sense
uh and there was jeff jarrod there so no
it's a four a four-person match jeff
jarrod
and and uh diamond dallas paige eric
bischoff who was like uh the man
like the vince mcmahon of the company
wrestling with him and me
and uh and you emerged the heavyweight
champion
i really blame the referee though if you
look back at the tape
if you look back the debut you know
diamond doll's page
clearly pinned uh uh
eric bischoff i mean uh uh jeff jarrod
but then the referee slid by and just
count
it was uh i mean we know we know that it
was predetermined
you were gonna be the champion so i
didn't want to at first either i was
like this is a terrible idea
but then diamond dallas page said to me
well listen
if you don't do it then this whole
thing's over ready rumble's over you're
not promoting it anymore
it's just they're not right and then if
you do do it you'll go all the way to
the pay-per-view
and i was like wait can i get to i get
to like travel with you guys it's like
yeah bro you're gonna be a bunch of
matches you travel with us you go
i was like flying on an airplane with
hulk hogan and sting and it was like
like a kid in a candy store because i
was telling them
well it does kind of make sense that i'm
like the first fan to ever
be they call them marks sometimes i'm
not actual mark
like i i and people think it's bad to
say that who cares
but uh it comes from the old kearney
term when they pat you on the back with
like some
chalk and they if they saw you buying
stuff so they see your
mark you could get him to do anything
you know what i mean
right so i was like listen i'm the first
mark to really become champion and they
and then
they looked around and these were all
marks
that's what he said but i was like no
but they didn't get like i'm the first
fan
so i saw it as a fan finally living a
fan's dream
like i thought it'd be interesting for
fans but it wasn't they took it really
personally it kind of like destroyed
santa claus for him
um oh dude i mean so the the reason why
we went into such
detail to paint this backdrop is because
it really affected you profoundly and
that's sort of the
the basis for your whole documentary is
that there was a lot of
like hating you know people were like
upset that that david
arquette became the heavyweight champion
and it
really hurt your feelings because the
only reason that you were doing that is
because you
you cared so much about wrestling yeah i
mean
it mainly like i just hated how i was
like a smear on the sport and shortly
after that wcw
did crash and like i was attributed to
like the fall of wcw me and
vince russo the guy who was writing all
this stuff at the time
so i just kind of always left like a s
like a bad feeling in my chest and you
know it wasn't just that i'd also have
my
addiction issues and you know i did a
string of att commercials that were
kind of like bad for my career in a way
just but i don't know for whatever
reason it just like
you know it was all on a downward sort
of thing
and then so i had like this
heart thing happen you got two stints
yeah
how old were you when that happened that
was like two years ago it was it was two
years before the death
of the documentary yeah three years ago
something like that i don't know
but uh yeah the bad relationship blood
thinners too
yeah yeah you get on all these crazy
blood thinners for the year
after and when you're taking blood
thinners if you get any kind of a cut
it's just a blood bath yeah and
internally especially if you get cut
internally you could just die
because it's too thin and
it's it's crazy so they're telling me it
was
too dangerous to do but you know
i know all about that i mean dude it
read
throughout the documentary that what you
were doing with the with all this
wrestling
i mean you were just not you were
vulnerable
not just because of your age but because
of your heart because of like
plenty of things and and you were
getting hit like tremendously hard
oh dude it is so painful have you ever
tried dude i had the experience too
and like the thing is people are very
protective wrestlers
yeah you know they're protective of
their art and
and my experience being me going in the
wwe ring
i got beaten into a blackout i do not
remember leaving the ring like they
don't really want
like some hollywood hot shot to come in
there and and
to be honest that's kind of like a lot
of the matches bro it's not
right it's not like it's it's
choreographed but it's
[ __ ] painful bro it's like i never
knew how intense
it's more choreographed mma to a certain
degree i mean
a lot of the old-timers can do it a lot
better and they can make their shots
look
a lot of the new guys coming up came up
backyard wrestling it's a totally
different thing people are just kicking
people in the face yeah it's real [ __ ]
for sure and i remember when i did the
wwe we like kind of walked through
like that the main points of the match
and and we walked and i was like wow you
know it's pretty heavy but then when we
were actually live
during the event it was a whole other
story i was like hold on dude that's not
how we walked through it you know
like we're remembering forgetting but
did they take advantage of you
you might have like who were you
wrestling with you got mad at you yeah
oh they did this guy um umaga he's since
passed away the samoan bulldozer
and in his defense i did not know that
the match isn't isn't over until you
play dead and stop moving and so he hit
me and i'm like rolling around like oh
man that was crazy you know and he's
just like
don't do that you know and i can i
didn't know so he hit me again
and i'm like wait stop it's supposed to
be over and and because i was still
moving around
he kept hitting me and he kept hitting
me he hit me with his elbow he got a
cell
yeah he was teaching you a lesson that's
just uh that happens sometimes
you know you learn things in the ring
like some of the stuff that they say
they say okay so like for in wrestling
for instance and it's just like all the
way they speak
so they'll say uh what about a
piledriver let's say oh that sucks
like yeah oh okay what that means is
that hurts really bad and you should not
do it
when it sucks they downplay everything
because they're all tough
so they'll say it sucks which means
don't that's
super painful so you just have to like
you until you learn all these little
things
like i in my the death match i didn't
mean to keep going back to it but
he said something at some point he's off
this is where the ultra violence happens
sure i was like okay yeah this whole
thing is ultra violent we can get to the
death match but no no no
we don't have to but it's just a more
example of like
not knowing the term so then when
something happens you're like what the
[ __ ]
right let's just establish that you came
up with the idea
uh you know you were you were the
heavyweight champion for a period of two
weeks yeah
and then uh what was it
it haunted me for 20 years 18 years
later
you decide all right that's it i'm gonna
redeem myself in wrestling
yeah but when i went through the heart
stint thing
i was like i'm thinking i might die i'm
like
well my family loves me my kids love me
my wife kinda loves me
i think she loves it i hope she loves me
but uh
all in all you know i've done some
things i'm proud of some things i
i am not but all in all great life
you know it's a good time whatever
but [ __ ] that wrestling thing i wish
wrestling
and i was like what am i thinking about
wrestling in a like uh
like that it's so important so it always
been gnawing at me it happened before
the internet happened so when the
internet happened
started back up i was just always the
low bar the joke
and i was just like [ __ ] that i never
got to train properly
i didn't know what i was doing they they
didn't let me do anything they were just
trying to protect me not getting me hurt
so my thing was i would get beat up
someone would come and beat them up
and then they'd roll me on top of the
person and i'd win the match
like that's so it just added to me being
more of a [ __ ] than
i felt i was and i just didn't want to
them to i wanted to prove myself i
didn't want them to write the end of my
story for me
and i wanted to honor wrestling and do a
documentary like why did people get so
mad at me and understand it from a more
uh
interesting place and i learned a lot
like through it
i learned a lot about acting i learned a
lot about myself
captured a period in my life where i was
going through a lot of stuff i learned a
lot about
why i was you know drinking too much or
doing different stuff
oh my god there's plenty of that in the
documentary and uh
so so you get your ass beat this is what
we've arrived at you get your ass beat
over and over again once you decide to
get
you call it training but really like you
got your ass beat you wanted like you
said
you basically said i want to redeem
myself in the eyes of the wrestling
world
by just getting brutally beaten up like
to the point where you can't call it
fake and you can't say that i wasn't
actually a participant
in the violence of wrestling it's my
right on it well that's what
training and wrestling is they toughen
you up
so you're ready for anything you know
how to take
falls and and beats and like how to take
shots
and then how to sell properly how to
like
uh just you know there's all kinds of
things you
go through in a ring but you learn a lot
about
especially about acting like i learned
so much you wouldn't think like
people don't think wrestlers are like
the greatest actors or something but
what they do is
so much showmanship showmanship but also
there's this time element
in a ring where everything speeds up and
you you think like
you're taking so long to walk across the
ring
uh but you look back on it and you run
across the ring
you know what i mean it's this crazy
thing that everything
you speed everything up so you have to
learn in wrestling to slow down and
there's a saying that if you feel like
you're going slow
slow down you know what i mean because
you can't like
there's all this like you're playing to
all these different people
you're uh just telling a story without
words
you're just uh selling with your face
and with your emotion
it's really and i mean like to be fair
you were selling it with like a hematoma
coming out of your head
i took a lead in the face yeah that was
rj city my
tag team partners was crazy so when you
were talking about the training are you
talking about after tijuana because like
even before that i just
i just want everybody listening to this
to to really like
just kind of get that we see david
in every like like
wrestling scenario from from being with
these guys
in in mexico who are wrestling at the
stoplight in the middle of the street to
collect
change from the cars that are stopped at
red lights and by the way
those guys were the most impressive
performers
but those dudes are real legit they they
do that during the day because they've
done it since they were kids but they go
and they wrestle at the biggest arena in
mexico
and then that's just like their day job
and then at night they're
doing the you know the biggest arenas
and the biggest shows
it's insane that they do that on a
regular basis so you get your ass beat
by the
the panhandler wrestlers in the street
who are the most
incredible performers in the whole movie
you get your ass beat by
backyard wrestlers that was before
mexico right
right you get your ass beat in uh
like at the the wrestling legends
championship wrestling from hollywood
yeah a hot championship and then there's
the other ones that legends of wrestling
so you're you're in basically like
arenas
oh yeah the first day of shooting they
[ __ ] we got in this fight
in the the thing they got mad at me for
you know
it was was that with the nasty boys yeah
the nazi boys
we love each other now but back then
they were really mad at me it was the
first day of shooting
we called them up and said listen we're
coming down to interview eric bischoff
for the documentary uh we'd love to come
film your event
you know they're like no i can't film
the event right you wanted to get in the
ring on that one or
i wanted to yeah yeah i wanted to just
like do something
get sli let's start something up and i
said uh
they said you can't come filming our
thing no and i was like okay well we're
still
already booked all our flights let's go
down to
detroit and interview eric bischoff so
we we're planning to interview him the
next day
during the day but that evening we're
sitting and we're just doing b-roll and
we're sitting at the bar having a couple
drinks
and i'm sitting looking at eric and then
behind me all the wrestlers start to
pile in and it's the day before the show
the night before the show
and they're filming and we're filming
and we're talking
there's someone jerry saggs one of the
nasty boys grabs the camera and
throws it like just breaks the camera
and i was like what the hell is going on
because
i didn't know that they were going
around with the camera i thought it was
just like me and eric and i didn't even
know that all the wrestlers were the
people that just piled into the
the bar so this whole thing comes up
this big guy grabs me by the back of the
neck
and i'm like what happened what happened
like they broke the camera i was like
well and i looked over at him and i he
had this big long beard and i
grabbed his beard and i said if you
don't let go of my neck
and then his girlfriend punched me in
the ear and it was like the first day of
shooting
it's amazing it was pretty intense and
they got mad
and it's understandable there's a lot of
like respect and wrestling
there's a lot of honor and there's a lot
of like
stuff they've gone through they put
their lives like through so much pain
that they don't want like
outsiders right right plus they're
my take on it maybe i'm wrong but but my
take is that that there's
a sensitivity around the idea that it's
not
fighting you know like there's a there's
a staged element to it there's a
scripted element to it
it's predetermined who's gonna win so i
think
that's why you got such a hard time for
being given the the championship
not because like you did anything wrong
or you were a bad person or
anything negative to you but the fact
that you got given the
heavyweight championship really exposed
more it
it it exposed oh wait a second that made
that makes wrestling look fake
and granted it is yeah but that was over
the line
it's not fake it's just right right it's
it's it's theater
you ever see that interviewer the guy
asked that you know he's wrestling fake
and yeah
right right right right he said is that
fake
that's an open hand slap right the open
hand slaps a really bad
like that's essentially a punch with an
open hand so open hand slap
happens all the time you have no idea
how hard that hurts
right until it happens right i'm not
done i'm just you're right
with all that and especially the fact
that i was an actor
right you know like a girl i'm friends
he's like
you know just like at the time i think
that's why you took so much heat over it
that's why there was so much
visceral hatred aimed at you because
there's a sensitivity in the wrestling
community about
anything which makes wrestling seem fake
yeah and so you took that very
personally and you
it really really hurt you and so now you
i love wrestling
yeah i mean it's it's obvious you
genuinely love it and so
you get into this whole thing and you're
in all these different wrestling
situations
getting legitimately hurt which is just
great entertainment
and we get to the death match so in the
death match
it's it's kind of a combination between
the backyard wrestling
but it's in an arena it's sort of this
hybrid of like
the backyard and the legit wrestling and
so what that means is that they've got
these fluorescent light bulbs breaking
everywhere
they've got like they've got more and
more kind of like props in there you're
getting
like thrown through like legit furniture
which is completely
shattering and you're getting all beat
up and i don't i don't want to give away
what it is but at a point in this match
this death
match you there's clearly something
wrong
you know there's no results or violence
there's clearly something wrong and the
way that it's put together is so
masterful because as we always say
you see your hand go to your neck and
it's like
like what's that all about it's very
noticeable something's really wrong
and like you and you just kind of see
your your wheels turning in your head
and you're like okay i got something's
really wrong i gotta get out of the ring
but then as soon as you get out of the
ring you're like nope the match isn't
over and so you go back into the ring
with what is evidently like a situation
that's going on
and you go back into the ring get beat
up a little bit more get pinned the
match is over and then now
you leave the ring and you beeline it
for the hospital where it is revealed
that not only was something wrong but
it was absolutely life-threateningly
wrong
and and i think we should just let
people go and watch you cannot kill
david arquette to find out what was so
[ __ ] wrong
yeah and you know i wouldn't give it
away but uh how long were you in the
hospital after that match
oh i was in the hospital for like a week
or so they had to put they had to put
some stuff back together
well the first time i went to the
hospital they just sewed it up but then
the next day i went to actually at
nxt one of the wwe events
and uh i was feeling so like delirious
in there that i had to go and then i had
like an infection i had to go in
for at least two like week and a half
two weeks oh my god it was like when
they when they revealed what was wrong
it was like your heart sank it was just
like
holy [ __ ] and then that
is just the fact that you had that going
on
and and and thought to yourself i better
get back in the ring and finish this
match
that right there is your redemption in
my in my eyes like
the fact that you were passionate enough
about wrestling to take a completely
[ __ ] life-threatening situation and
disregard it
to go back into that ring and finish
that match like
if that's not wrestling then i don't
know what is and that was my favorite
line in the movie when the one guy said
that
yeah okay i mean it's it's complicated
as far as all that goes and i don't want
to reveal too much
either um
so i don't know we don't we don't we
don't yeah we don't we don't have to get
now
i did think i was dying though yeah
i uh i tried to pin the guy just to like
you know like if i'm dying let me win
but i wasn't supposed to win so
get out of here and luke perry was there
yeah
he drove you he was in the car that
drove you to the hospital
his son jack perry who's amazing
wrestler jungle boy
incredible dude that was that was your
your
your dopest move in the whole movie you
saved it for the last scene
yeah yeah that's uh that actually is
because of him
like whenever you look really good in a
wrestling match if you're not too
skilled it's typically because the other
person can make people look really good
i i would agree but that was a double
that was a two-man move yeah that's
called a canadian destroyer
it's really intense that was
that was like holy dude you ended on a
banger dude yeah
that last scene that last scene was like
holy [ __ ] because
i i particularly love acrobatics and
that was just a badass move so
uh what is it jack perry jack perry
jungle boy is his name
is a movie star he's gonna be a huge
star and that's luke perry's son
yeah and he's at aew which is another
emerging huge wrestling thing it's crazy
that a
few of the people like my trainer peter
avalon is uh
he trained me and he's the librarian at
aew he's a really incredible
wrestler he trained me in the backyard i
have a ring yeah and we just like
you know trained all the time a couple
times a week at least and uh
yeah and then now jack and a bunch of
guys come over and wrestle
it was really like what i always wanted
anyway just to sort of be a part of it
be one of the boys you know for sure for
sure
okay so there's also a big component of
the movie
uh as it relates to mental health and
and uh like addiction issues and there
was
there's this one scene that
i i mean i don't know how much you want
to say about it if you don't even want
to say what kind of a treatment it was
but where you're losing your mind and
that
yeah that's hard for me to watch i
actually they kicked i'm one of the
producers
my wife really produced this whole movie
she at first she didn't believe
like she's like what are you doing
wrestling she's like didn't understand
wrestling she thought it was all
like dumb the fact that i'm doing a
documentary about it she thought was
dumb
she didn't believe it but then once it
started she was like okay and she's kind
of like that she
she likes to control her stuff but in a
great way because
we wouldn't have got it done without her
and yeah she's like the voice of reason
a little bit you know absolutely but
she's literally like booking flights
like she did everything getting camera
package she's a badass wow
and then dude this part is just really
important to me and props to your wife
for doing a great
ketamine yeah i did a ketamine treatment
and i was like oh please don't show that
now ketamine like it's this is so
important to me because ketamine was
like
among my favorite drugs of choice
i don't even have a drug of choice
because i loved them all but i
but ketamine like i and i never injected
it though i
i always like uh cooked it and snorted
it
right but uh but now like it's presented
it's presented in the film
by an actual doctor that that
there's some sort of therapeutic value
to
just shooting you up with a bunch of
kids that was a lot
yeah they did a bunch in that one this
is about to get real
heavy and you're gonna love listening to
it just like i love listening to stuff
with my
raycon everyday earbuds
these are half the price of any other
premium earbuds and they come in this
little cool case
that charges them up so they pretty much
last forever and you can control them
like push the button stop skip track all
the way
and half these other premium earbuds
don't even have
controls like that they fit right in my
ears so
perfectly comfortably i can lay down on
a pillow
and no problem dude i don't go
anywhere without them that's why i have
a standing promise that if you ever see
me in public
anywhere and i don't have them in my
pocket
or my ears slash both then
i'll do your voicemail greeting video
shout outs for you and your buddies
i don't care because i'm never getting
busted without it because i
love my raycon earbuds so much
i never go anywhere without them so it's
time for you to get yourself some
again they're half the price of any
other premium earbuds
how do you get them you go to buy raycon
dot com
slash stevo that's b u y
r a y c o n
dot com slash stevo and you're gonna get
fifteen percent off your order that's
again 15 off your order at byraycon.com
devo you're going to thank me for it
because i love these things now
let's get back into the academy and and
so i've done it like three times in a
doctor's office the
other two times is more where it's not
as much and you stay awake and you have
a real therapy session on ketamine which
is really healthy oh my god i'm dude i'm
as a ketamine addict i was watching that
footage and this is like
one of the more notable scenes in a
bonkers ass movie you're you're losing
your [ __ ] mind on camera like your
dude in that scene they give you all
this ketamine and do you just
turn into this thing which you can't
even describe
you can't even describe what happens in
this [ __ ] scene
and i'm sitting there watching it
thinking oh my god if there's anything
therapeutic about ketamine sign me up
no kidding i mean it is dangerous with
addiction like things but what
one of the things that it does do is it
resets your uh neural receptors
so if you really are kind of tweaked out
it can
get you down to a thing it also like
with the right kind of therapy
i mean i don't know it was helpful to me
more so to do it and with
the doctor who who gave it to me and
then my actual
therapist so i dealt with all these
things because it's a dissociative
anesthetic oh my god i love it it's also
a you know it's
i love it kind of hallucinogenic thing
big time and it's not even just like
hallucinating
it did you ever go in a cage
it completely distorts your your depth
perception
you're talking about the the dude i was
there experiences you had dad
i remember one time i was in a bat i was
in a bathtub and like my feet
i'm looking at my feet they're like 30
[ __ ] feet away like i mean it was
like
you know the depths were like i was in a
hotel room and the [ __ ] whole hotel
room just started
free falling like i'm in it and i and
i'm like what the [ __ ] i'm free falling
and i looked up and i could actually see
like uh like like a shaft that through
which the elevator
that's like not an elevator the hotel
room was falling
and i was just like oh my god having
this experience i remember thinking like
jim morrison doesn't have [ __ ] on me
i was just like yeah i thought that was
my that was my thought i was like
this is the coolest oh by the way
dude then your documentary i was like oh
man i saw some of the monster faces and
i was like oh i'd gone to the dark side
a few times but
i mean more than a few times but i'd
seen that dark side
and that's a you know that's a real
scary monster place to go
yeah especially cocaine and speed [ __ ]
like that is just like ah
did the ketamine treatments help they
did man
they did you know like specifically i
was thinking about my
my parents and their relationship that
they had a like troubled relationship
we're always
arguing about money and i had this
little heavy pain
and i'm like wait they're they're both
dead
and i was like i was like turn to my
doctors and they're like yeah i was like
so all that pain is just in me
they're like kind that's exactly where
it is i mean it's
you know there's generational pain that
no matter if people are gone
it still lives there so then you have to
figure out how to lift it
how to get rid of it and that session
alone did
lift it quite a bit after the session
did you feel like you wanted to
do more were you like [ __ ] i wish i
would do more candidly
no i mean that's the problem you have to
like get to a place
where you like the
attic thing that's a whole thing that
you have to like
figure out be it through a program be it
through like
just you know to self working on
yourself
but i was like through that whole
process i
started figuring out and with the death
match like why am i doing this why am i
like hurting myself or you know and it
went to a bunch of different stuff like
i found myself getting really mad with
my wife one time when
she did something that made me feel
stupid and i was like
okay she didn't mean it that way after i
could get my
wits about me she didn't mean it that
way and i was flashed when i was a kid
like i couldn't read and and i had
dyslexia and this one teacher put me in
front of the class and
i was like like it just made me feel
stupid so then
i had gone through life feeling like
you're just stupid you're
so stupid like just telling you so what
that does is it creates a neural pathway
within your brain that there's
i'm just stupid neural pathways so when
that loop
yeah exactly so it's these rabbit holes
we go down shame whatever it is
like i'm a piece of [ __ ] whatever that
is
you [ __ ] don't deserve to live
whatever that is a neural pathway so
what you have to do is
reset your neural pathways you can do it
with anything
you could there's this book called love
yourself like your life depends on it
and that is a just a process of saying i
love myself i love myself and they're
what i use
to combat the self-abuse part so then
you start this neural pathway that's
i love myself and like when i start
feeling some of that sid as
silly as it sounds i'll repeat it in my
head i'll
breathe and do it out loud i'll do
different exercises and meditations to
to set new neural pathways so you set
these new neural pathways so when you
see yourself going down that one it's
like oh no go to this one
and then once they're thick enough they
start going down those neural pathways
it's like oh i'm not a piece of [ __ ] i
love myself i'm awesome this is great i
love myself and does the ketamine allow
you to be like honest about it is it
like just an a to b
quick route to like so ketamine lasts
you know a couple hours or something
you know it's like a tree not if you
keep doing it exactly that's the whole
thing
with any kind of addiction and stuff but
i've noticed that if like
even if i smoke pot or if i have a
couple drinks
that lasts like the the
energy me getting upset you know
just just it it affects me
yeah you know so you have to start
seeing like how do you want to engage in
the world
and like how do you want to be because
i've tried a and all that stuff and i
just not i don't know i know it works
for a lot of people and i i love it
i really do the men's the whole process
that whole stuff is
incredible but i couldn't like be sober
all the time but you know i'm finding
now that
i am sober all the time i'm it's
more healthy for me but i'm doing the
neural pathway stuff and the positive
kind of things and i've i've figured out
that when i do
charity it makes me feel really good
when i like exercise it makes me feel
really good and then you start
when you reset all your neural receptors
you're like oh
it's you you it's almost like your life
becomes and then you find like how can
you laugh more and that's the drug i
want to learn how to do
so then how do i do a life that's filled
with more joy and happiness
you know what i mean and then you become
living this drug
that we're always kind of searching for
but a lot of the drugs that you do
have effects or if you're an addict like
i am you just want to go
deep into it so yeah i had to like not
do
ketamine anymore right you know what i
mean you know i did it for a little
period of time i did some um
micro dosing of it which is almost like
it helped a little but it's like
maybe a little scratch that and i'm in
charge of this
palette of [ __ ] little things that
i'm chipping one little piece off a day
where an addict is just like yeah yeah
you did the the
horrifying underdose
anything but the underdogs we were doing
a stunt one time and it was like
uh for steve was like take one cialis
and steve's like give me four
yeah i always did that too yeah extra
yeah
right yeah how can you cope and like the
whole thing like can i maintain
like i did this one thing
like this one project was the only one
that i'd ever been
sort of high on but uh i i was like
can i stay up all night and on all this
and still maintain tomorrow
and uh not so good now
you said that like uh you know i mean
the whole 12 step you know that you
can't
do that and i think the position of
anybody
in our position we're total full-on
sober dudes
and the position of any like really
sober person is
look if you can pull it off like you
know
we don't care like like we don't like
care if you
you know do it or don't do it we just
like that's what it's all about is like
hey if you find that when you take
a drink that you can't control how much
you drink and you can't stop
drinking and then and if you find that
over and over and over and over
then we present to you that maybe you
should do what we do but
brother if you can like drink sometimes
and then stop completely
you know moderate then our hands
a slippery slope because it's the
addict's like job to
kill you that's what it wants to do it
wants to [ __ ]
kill you no matter what so it could be a
long
walk down a long plank but you know what
i mean
so i know that so i don't want to ever
do that
and i also want to do things i just i
know also that
all of my worst decisions that i've ever
made
have been sort of either when i'm drunk
or something
right so i just don't want to make those
same mistakes anymore
sure but i have had the experience that
i can
have a glass of wine and you know just
like that
and it's the underdose
you definitely want more but you know
you also don't like
i don't know i'm sick of like regretting
[ __ ]
i mean dude if you can pull it off have
a glass of wine and then
and then stop our hats are off to you
brother we we totally
we're totally cool with that um now
uh and dude like we're big howard stern
fans so we heard all those crazy calls
but speaking of like bad decisions oh
yeah i know regretful crazy times i i
remember really feeling for you because
i had known that you were sober for a
period before that
and it was like oh okay david's not
sober anymore yeah
um and and dude you were not in a good
place on those calls but like especially
those last ones
i was really bitter and angry what
happens too is it doesn't become fun
anymore
you were furious at the world for not
being loving enough
you were straight up furious
yeah so so there's that and
dude you seem like you're in a great
place now so we got no judgment no
complaints no
um you said just before about
uh like you know this this pain around
your parents and in your family
by people arguing about money and that
really
is is uh seems interesting to me because
in your family i can't imagine that
money is an
issue for most anybody right like how
many how many brothers and sisters do
you have
uh alive two brother uh one brother and
two
sisters okay and uh the sisters are
patricia and rosanna arkansas yeah and
then richmond's my brother
you know richard's the best he's got the
best like arquette trivia
ever because he's like he's an actor too
but a writer
a a writer mainly and then uh
he's the guy who delivered the box to
brad pitt and seven
that's right what's in the box i don't
know man
that's my brother that's my favorite wow
yeah he's in all of david
pitcher's movie a lot of them but that
was a great [ __ ] movie man
so yeah not really but when we were
growing up yeah
we weren't like rich kids or anything
you know not even right
you were born on a commune we were born
on a commune and it was
you know something like river phoenix
[ __ ] yeah kind of yeah
this sort of philosophy from indonesia
and like 30 people came to live in this
place in in in fort
[ __ ] i forgot front royal virginia
and then the guy who started it from
indonesia comes and he says
what are you doing isolating yourself in
the middle of nowhere
this philosophy is about it yeah this
philosophy is about
learning what your special gift is and
going out in the world and making the
world a better place so if you're an
actor you should be
where they're doing films and plays and
if you're an architect you should be
where they're building houses and
apartment buildings how long were you
living there when he came and said that
i was only like
three or four or something i was born
there and we left around four
so he broke up everyone moved so we
moved to chicago and then we moved to
l.a
and we were like you know my grandfather
was this character named charlie weaver
cliff arquette he that's a tattoo of him
the hollywood squares
yeah he was in the bottom left square
and uh
and he he was great everything and when
he died we got enough to get a house but
we didn't like
my dad was a working actor so whether
it's strikes it was
tough times if he got a commercial and
you know nationwide commercial we'd
like get good christmas presents but
it's not like we had any kind of like
silver spoon and so my mom and dad would
argue a lot about just stuff
like just in general my dad was you know
a
pretty rascally guy and you know
uh she was like a lot of stuff so so
which of your siblings was the first i
presume it was
rosanna yeah yeah after uh my dad and
and everybody but yeah rosanna broke
down the she broke the wall down for
this generation she came out
when she was like 15 or 15 and she
ran away from home stayed with the
family here that
our family knew and she actually went
into an audition and uh
the story goes i have to talk to her
about it again
but she went to uh she read about this
like character who had epilepsy and
she got somehow got the the sides and
went to the office
and sat there all day and the casting
director came out and she was like
do you have an appointment and she's
like uh
no and then uh they're like okay
and then they sort of left everybody and
and at the end of the day they're like
i'm sorry well
you don't have an appointment she's like
oh all right i was just
thinking maybe i could audition for it
she got up to walk and she like
hit the ground and started having an
epileptic fit and they're like oh no no
everyone freaked out and she was acting
and then they were blown away and she
got the part yeah that's epic
the first time i remember her in like
god i would i want to see it was like
1985 and
in the movie with madonna yeah
definitely seeking susan yeah right so
that was uh
she had a that was a big break for her
yeah but she had a career
for a while before that yeah a while
before that yeah she worked with betty
davis
she's wow she's a tremendous tremendous
it was cool to see her in your in your
dock i mean she's been out of the public
eye
yeah sort of i mean she's been doing
stuff that's this business
it's so crazy you know what i mean
you're like you know she's
[ __ ] bad ass like she should be
getting all the
roles she wants you know what i mean but
it's just this crazy [ __ ] business
where you're
hot and you're not that's sort of we
talk about a little of that
and it's sort of attributed to like
the wrestling really brought me but
that's not really the true stories
my drinking falling into howard stern
you know
doing certain things like being out i
have a nightclub called bootsy bellows
so being out there getting caught on tmz
all drunk and just acting stupid
doing those commercials she was like
choosing
badly in the roles because it's really
specific if you want to build a career
you have to be really specific
about what you do some people don't work
for two years until that right role
comes back
up and it's all they're really specific
they don't strategic
yeah strategic and i've never been like
that i like to work
we've always been like working actors so
i'll do something
a kids show or i'll do this and but
people frown on that
the uh the the part i think that you're
talking about in the documentary
it's really kind of like sad it's
towards the beginning and you're driving
your car
and and you're saying man you know i've
been uh
auditioning for roles for the last 10
years and i keep not
getting the roles but you said imagine a
job imagine going to a job interview
10 years in a row and you never get the
job but you just keep shooting up and
go for another interview and i just
remember thinking man
like uh it was so like genuinely brave
for you to be that vulnerable for you to
be that candid
and be like hey look you know like i've
been getting rejected for 10 years
like that and for have that having that
at the beginning of the documentary
it's like wow david's not doing this
this documentary to make himself
look good you know like right out of the
gate he's coming out and saying
that's also them making a movie and
that's also like i had notes in the
editing room it's part of the reason i
got pulled out
you know because i had worked within
that ten years but it's only
if somebody offered me something yeah
you know that's right right right it's
just i didn't get
a job off of an audition and i said it
right after that but they're
you know when you get down in the
editing room it's like you need seconds
so they're like
we just have to slice that out so it's a
little misleading
there's a couple of things that are a
little misleading but it's
you know it's like it's true in its
essence but it's like wrestling
sorry to cut you off yeah like wrestling
we're in that it's choreographed but
it's still
real absolutely that's the whole that's
the whole movie and that's the whole
sort of situation i loved that
and and there was something just so
genuine about the way that you said that
that
that like you know was it was it was
profound it was impactful
and i remember thinking like as i saw
that i was like
well [ __ ] you know like you think of
david arquette as uh
you know like a really successful guy i
do you know i think of you as like a
really successful guy
in the movie you've got this beautiful
gated home
which is like clearly uh you know
just a expensive lifestyle it's it
it reads and then if we put it together
well if he hasn't been working that much
in his career he's got this big
beautiful like
you know los angeles gated mansion
then like and i think oh yeah it's
because he owned the
bootsy bellows nightclub situation so
was that like really really profitable
for you
oh it was like that it was like this
does good and all that but
no i mean not really you know
i mean if you want to be brutally
i just moved to nashville because
there's no state tax
for a much cheaper house i mean just to
keep
up with the joneses in los angeles is
expensive you know what i mean so this
being that yes i have
i did well it's all in perspective i
mean
what people are going through right now
i just can't even imagine
i'm like so oh i feel it so
i'm just for the next part of my life
it's all going to be
charity based it's all going to be oh
dude
a [ __ ] thing that i did construct
different than any other corporation
dude talking about charity
um like one of my favorite people in the
world is
the legend tony hawk right and and when
the
when the pandemic started tony hawk
put on his instagram this unbelievable
photo they went to a
like an empty water park and this
gigantic
tube thing he did a loop around you know
and he's like
they got this photo where he's upside
down at midnight doing this loop on this
like 20 foot tall
tube and he signed 2 000 prints of this
picture
sold them and donated 100 of the profits
to covid relief that's so difficult and
i was inspired by that so i went
and did this crazy stunt doing a flip
off of a building and the photographer
shot a sequence like
that so the print was just one photo of
the building but there were
seven of me doing a flip off the roof
looked really cool and i signed
1500 of them and sold them all for
charity and i gave up
i gave a 100 of the of the proceeds
to a food bank in albuquerque new mexico
best man
yeah i love food banks worth of feeding
america a lot it's such an important
asset so now here i can my [ __ ] head
exploded when i had this idea
it came from tony hawk take a dope ass
[ __ ] picture
sign like you know a thousand or however
just sign a [ __ ] ton of them and then
sell them
and donate 100 of the proceeds to
charity
i was inspired by tony hawk doing it i
did it myself
and then i thought holy [ __ ] what if it
became a [ __ ] thing
called the 8 by 10 challenge where
we nominate i
nominate you to take a [ __ ] photo
and sign it and [ __ ] sell and sell it
and donate
and then you nominate someone else can
you imagine if that actually spread
in any capacity how what a staggering
amount of [ __ ] money would be raised
for charity
so tony hawk and i are going to get
together and shoot a double
photo where i i go up a ramp and i'm
riding along a wall
and he's going to be off a bigger ramp
riding over me in the same picture
i love it yeah i did i did a double
picture with jon jones the ufc
champ and uh yeah dude i mean i don't
know
i put it out there man i think if uh i
think it's a solid way
to to raise money for charity awesome
yeah there's this whole wrestling
group that approached me to do something
to sign
just for this gift thing but i'll i'll
do that i told him i didn't want to do
it because
i don't i don't know i guess that's not
charity though we should
figure out how to deal with charities
and in in your movie
you you know to have this photo shoot to
take uh you know
like media shots or whatever you know
like to sign
i mean i think that you could tie it
into promoting
the action tie it into promoting the
movie and like when you're when you're
doing press be like hey man like i've do
for charity i've got my wrestling
headshots
pick pick one of them i like the magic
man one yeah i would love that one
i don't know where we printed a few of
them
that chick needs to get unlimited dude
maybe we'll do the magic man as yeah
tried
i mean dude and there's got to be like
some kind of a covered in blood
shot or like you know like some super
gnarly
action wrestling shot which like
represents for you like the craziest
moment
like the most powerful [ __ ] my whole
thing is like i
i've done these signings and stuff and
like and i
i don't want to mess with wrestling and
and a lot of people
it's part of it it's a little late to
not mess with wrestling
but i always feel bad like i don't know
i i'm conflicted
i'm trying to come up with this you can
sell them online i know i'm trying to
come up with a corporation so
a corporation's job is to limit
human capital you know what that is
human capital
yeah there's human capital within every
corporation and it's a number
and it's the corporation's job to reduce
that number
so we mean to reduce expenses yeah so
that you can increase
profits yes okay but human capital and
that number represents
people right so human capital is people
you know it's literally people so a
corporation's job is to eliminate people
and then nobody's talking about it so i
want to figure out how to create a
corporation
where you measure it by the number of
human capital that you're
i think a good example of that yes
that's it like that's the game like you
have to prove
to corporate america that the corporate
capitalist structure is completely wrong
and that's by it's a i don't know it's a
big [ __ ] test but the next thing i
want to do
is sort of in that world like how do you
create a charity and
a corporation from it that then
is sort of doing that give us the next
argument
yeah but dude if there's any sensitivity
on your part
about taking a a [ __ ] like explosive
photo of you wrestling with covered in
blood
flying through the air whatever it is
whatever is that dopest photo
like dude don't be bashful about signing
those [ __ ] things for charity dude no
i don't know
i don't i'm not i wouldn't be for
charity but i always feel
like you go to these horror festivals
for instance and you sign a bunch of
stuff and it just feels
i don't know i know it's i know it's a
lot of people's livelihood because
you know some a lot of the people at
those festivals are literally living off
these festivals and i get it
i get it but i always feel sort of
compromised i wish there could be like
i just don't like the idea of people who
might not be able to afford it
like coming to meet me and sign
something
you know what i mean like if like
instead of like
putting food on the table kind of stuff
i just always get like
emotional like push-pull and
i think that you're picturing the
signing being something that happens
in person like at a convention where
what we're talking about
is you get a box of a thousand of them
you put it on there yeah
but yeah my whole thing is just that
whole someone's buying it
right right right right i know i just
i'm more i think i'm a socialist
at heart like hardcore where it's like
now that
literally what we're seeing right now
happened i was like an andrew yang fan
and i read it yeah
man i read his book and it just made so
much sense you see all these malls
closing
like all this stuff's been happening for
years right and it's
in the whole the wealth inequities and
the whole kind of thing
so like how do we address that and then
i don't know how can we get like base
stuff for people taking care of where
their house
their food their clothing their
education right and their health care is
just covered
so people aren't [ __ ] so stressed
right like not robbing as much and like
having to do that
you know what i mean like start a
commune in one of those empty shops
no i know well have you ever been to
burning man
now [ __ ] incredible system of
like life where essentially you know
people set up these different camps
where they
you know will be having grilled cheese
at four o'clock or
this person's doing a turkey dinner you
know what i mean you just different
places and
you know you could get clothes at this
place give
give a shirt and get a shirt you know
it's this whole bartering system but it
for that like two week period i think it
is
it's the second largest city in utah
um is it india wait not nevada
yeah it's it becomes larger than reno or
something
for that too yeah so when you go in you
get an actual um
i would have checked it out before i got
sober
you can go sober i know they have like
i'd want to go no
no not even like that dude it's like a
drug being there
right you when i'm there like i've been
there so sober
you want my shirt for a [ __ ] syringe
full of smack
yep yeah yeah i know i mean
yeah you got to be careful yeah i mean
and whatever dude i think it's
no but it's like a drug being there like
i i'm you're every year i'm there i'm
like
being like you're in a total windstorm
dirt storm you're sitting there i'm like
why the [ __ ] do i do this
i'd be down to like take a helicopter
out there for a day yeah you counts
you can they frown on it but yeah
yeah well you bring this kind of thing
yeah this would be different i agree
yeah let's bring that
but then when this the dust clears then
you see the most incredible art you've
ever imagined like the place is like the
greatest collection of artists you've
ever imagined and there's
weird [ __ ] like such cool crazy [ __ ]
like in the middle of nowhere
the biggest game of
operation just sitting on the ground
like a huge
where it's like huge things like you
pick the big
fish bo the fish bone out and go i mean
it's really nose lights up
i've been three times at times yeah but
i do it they're
different like kind of the way people
probably found them
i don't i don't know that burning man is
the solution
to the world's problems i i couldn't
agree with you more
that wealth inequity like uh like these
[ __ ]
you don't need that much to even live
the most lavish lifestyle
so it's like all these guys they wait
till they're dead to donate their money
and do it in different ways
like i i just would be santa claus
i don't know if people like i don't know
i don't know i know
people think like well you gotta work
and of course people work they'll be
more like
jazzed up about working i don't know the
problem is the the human ego
and the idea of survival this separation
like you know i'm separate i gotta take
care of myself
and like the human nature is the more
you
acquire the more you feel you need like
i've seen that there are surveys of
people
who uh at all different wealth you know
levels
and it's so [ __ ] shocking that
that that the people who they survey who
have like
over 10 million dollars
net worth are the ones who describe
feeling the most
financially insecure wow like that
you know so like greed like greed just
[ __ ] grows and becomes like crazier
and crazier and like
that's the the the key to the world's
problems
is to for people to stop being so
[ __ ] goddamn greedy
but it's just not in our human nature
and so this whole problem with the
wealth
the the the rich getting richer the poor
getting poorer
like i see the whole society that i see
the whole world on this track
that just straight bums me out and
that's why i got a vasectomy dude
i straight up don't wanna i [ __ ]
don't wanna have kids because it's like
you know our parents you know our our
parents generation
if they went to university they got a
diploma from university
that meant placement in a career of
their choice
and then for our generation you know the
people who graduated from university
you know they had a better shot if they
if they got a diploma
you know they had a better shot but it
wasn't a guarantee anymore and now
for our kids generation going to [ __ ]
university all that means is just
burden of student [ __ ] debt dude
like it's just it's downright [ __ ]
sad how opportunity
in the world just dwindles and dwindles
and this propped up [ __ ] ponzi scheme
that that our like that you know
american economy
is where it's just the rich needing to
get so much [ __ ] richer and [ __ ]
the poor just
screwing them over so much that the
whole thing is just propped up on
toothpicks and now along comes this
corona virus
which just blew it all out it was
already a bubble
waiting to get popped so yeah i'm with
you man my heart [ __ ] breaks
for uh for what people are going through
right now man and that's why i'm so
jazzed
to get on the the eight by ten channels
like whatever it is
yeah oh dude i love it i love it dude i
[ __ ] love it and
i would i mean i don't know dude i would
uh
if there's a photo to set up in the back
in your ring
wrestling ring in the back dude i'd be
pretty we should
after this we should jump into your ring
and see what kind of a dope ass photo we
can get
for sure i i got the back flip off the
top rope
i think you can pull a back flip outside
yeah dude like like at my age now like
it's the back flip on flat ground i'm
more afraid of but you give me that top
rope and
i get more room to rotate do you still
have the ring david i do yeah man
are you so you're moving to tennessee
yeah
are you going to bring the ring no no
the ring will stay here
i don't know yeah another round give it
to jack perry
yeah are you really are you bringing
that giant chair
with you the dead chairs yeah that's in
uh
that [ __ ] thing is cool i love that
chair are you sitting in there just
talking about like
just i just want to be a kid i don't
want a girl that's
so funny yeah i found that that chair on
like uh
fairfax years ago there was some like
photographer's chair and he used it for
these photos
yeah i always used to collect big [ __ ] i
think i know the place you're talking
about on la brea
yeah yeah yeah i forget the name of it
but you bought something there i'll tap
on a bunch of stuff there
yeah yeah oh that weird on the corner
the
yeah yeah nick metropolis oh yeah that
guy
yeah okay well dude i think uh
you know i think we got heavy at the end
yeah that was good
it's fine i don't mind a bit i'm dying
to ask you one quick question because
when i was watching the doc
the first backyard wrestling match you
went to you didn't coordinate anything
with any of those guys
you went out there and you pulled
something out of your pants
and you just hit this [ __ ] guy in the
face did he even know that was coming
yeah so you'd say yeah yeah
and you just came out and did that and
then he [ __ ] punched you pretty good
yeah i was just sitting there thinking
like was that planned or there's no
[ __ ] way
uh you know he just
yeah dude i i said i didn't know like
you know there's all kind of the
director and stuff they sort of
mapped out the where i was going and
stuff like that i came up with the magic
man stuff i had all these
i wanted them to play that was like the
first match that you were in in the
movie and i was like
this guy you're already owning it dude
it's sick it's also so well
shot the whole thing like some of those
shots are so beautiful david dawg
and james price are incredible
filmmakers david darks the the main
shooter and he's just got he's like you
know
incredible gets nominated for his short
films and he's just
he he went to ebola the uh somewhere in
africa when
ebola broke out and was filming that
[ __ ] like he's hardcore yeah dude
everything i know there's another
question that scott wants to ask
i'm going to ask it for him but in the
scene where you're doing the spray
tanning
yeah like and you've got you're wearing
nothing you're getting spray tan you're
wearing nothing except this little
this little thing over your wiener [ __ ]
yeah i was like damn
dude david's got a huge dawn
not like you were trying to do mirrors
it's all of work
no no no dude like you were you're
robust
down there
that's so hardcore if you haven't seen
gnarly you just gotta
that was intense oh dude thank you so
much man
do you guys have more questions i do
want to say one thing in the beginning
of your movie david you
you quickly referenced your like and
then he made all these movies then he
made c-spot run just for the money
right you said that i love that i love
c-spot
nice that actual song was written like
after i did scream two or something
by a band called the black math
experiment
and they wrote this song and i got in
touch with them on myspace
and they like said it to me and i was
like oh that's funny that you did it but
it was my wife's idea to include it in
the film as like sort of like a get to
know who
i am at the beginning good call i love
it yeah i love it thank you man
yeah man i just wanted to say that dude
i love it
i mean dude your [ __ ] career's been
been pretty impressive man [ __ ]
impressive
thank you it's killer i uh i i
didn't even know about a bunch of those
movies that they highlighted and
so are you still doing like crazy [ __ ]
all right howdy and stuff
why what tomorrow dude we gotta
for anybody listening this was recorded
the day before
i went to go do the spinal cavity
injection [ __ ] 30-yard dash
or however many yards it takes oh
getting a you're gonna
um they do they inject a uh they inject
into my spinal cavity
a drug called chloroprokane
which uh which won't give me a buzz or
anything i won't like uh
get high but it will just straight
paralyze me from the waist down like my
legs will go completely paralyzed
and i'm gonna we don't have a straight
jacket maybe we'll just tie my hands
behind my back or give me a
hand probably i had a straight jacket
and it's in nashville oh
[ __ ] maybe we'll maybe get one at that
i'll [ __ ] we should get a [ __ ]
straight jacket dude we gotta let's go
to a prop house or something on the way
home
but yeah dude so they're gonna have like
a thing in my spine
and this it sounds crazy a spinal cavity
injection but it's actually pretty
pretty safe you can get one at the magic
apple right here
ah brad and and so they'll plunge it in
and like please like on your mind like
it's like on your market set plunge and
i'm just gonna start sprinting
so i'd like but so i'm gonna run until
my legs
until my legs are paralyzed hopefully
i'll eat [ __ ] like crazy
but then how long does it last 45
minutes my legs will be paralyzed
so i'll be on the ground and i can't get
up and i can't run away from the guys
doing me and [ __ ] to me okay
i mean i get it but i get you it's for
another
it's it's for another project yeah it's
the fun it's the follow-up to gnarly
yeah
that is gnarly
yeah oh man it's gonna be great man
maybe there'll be like some
some uh thing you learned there's gonna
be something
from i mean whatever learn like i don't
know if i learned anything but i
sure i sure love getting killer [ __ ]
footage man like
and i got a racing neck brace and a
racing helmet so that like it prevents
my oh good good
pretty like i can eat [ __ ] pretty much
any way i want i'm not gonna break my
neck and that's all i care about oh
that's cool
yeah good so at least you're being safer
about it yeah yeah and and uh
and i got like an actual medical
professional who's gonna be in disguise
oh good good good
so yeah dude that's a good one and again
i love getting footage and that's
tomorrow
and then oh [ __ ] before i even even if i
can hint at the next one because i know
but
but the next one's going to happen
before this comes out
you'll see yeah you want to tell them
what you already did i'll tell them what
i already do dude
you know you know how i got [ __ ] ah
i'm telling them okay you know how in
the beginning of gnarly that all the
jackass guys duct tape me into the truck
and it's a billboard truck dude we're
getting
a [ __ ] billboard in the middle of
hollywood like an
actual one that you drive by and it's
gonna be the same billboard gnarly
we're going in there with [ __ ] cherry
pickers you know like the the thing that
extends up
and we're [ __ ] duct taping me to my
own billboard in the middle of hollywood
and we're [ __ ] leaving me up there
and it says right there available at
stevo.com
yeah so that's next i love that because
it doesn't seem as
self-abusive yeah well i mean
i know but now i'm trying to yeah david
i'm curious what's your
takeaway from all this wrestling like
you talked kind of earlier about like
why do i do this
have you kind of just a self-love i just
had to figure out how to love myself
and not beat the [ __ ] out of myself i
mean one thing's for sure
is that that to to do that to go back to
wrestling because you wanted to get
redemption from the haters
please tell me you at least learned that
you're never going to get redemption
from haters
it's like responding to a negative
comment on social media
no matter what you respond with you're
never gonna
[ __ ] get through to a hater you're
never you're just you can't engage with
them
you can't [ __ ] you just gotta block
them and move on
yeah you know silence is the deadliest
weapon
silence is the only response to [ __ ]
haters because if you give them any kind
of energy
you're just feeding them you're feeding
them you're empowering them
and [ __ ] them for sure
yeah nice thank you yeah
i did i did yeah and you know you made a
great documentary which is cool
and it's like to the people who are
gonna hate you anyway
they're just gonna take you know and
that's what what [ __ ] pissed me off
because
here you got like you know you're doing
all this like super intense wrestling no
matter how intense it is
it's either oh you went from he doesn't
belong in wrestling or
man he's being he's [ __ ] like uh
an idiot beating himself up to it you're
never gonna win with these people never
you know
exactly what you did to redeem yourself
it just
lands it just it just lands with some
kind of other judgment you know
so dude like like i think that the
lesson in all of that
is you do what the [ __ ] you want to do
for
you because it makes you feel good and
[ __ ] everybody else
thank you bro you too and i just don't
want you to hurt yourself
oh when i saw i've been burned i've been
i got this crazy [ __ ] burn
but uh yeah it uh yeah i was just
and that was just on my hand like i
can't imagine
yeah dude i know man it's it's it's
intense
see i don't know where to go from there
man thank you i think it's good you're
in [ __ ] great shape dude
it's really good to hang with you
brother yeah we're about the same age
man
we both look great
[Laughter]
yeah yeah dude it's crazy man like did
you go to high school
fairfax high school yeah and like people
in high school people who you were in
high school with
isn't it amazing how they look like [ __ ]
i know yeah
like uh not everybody's lucky like we
have our hair still i don't feel [ __ ]
i don't know we look pretty much like we
always looked
yeah yeah pretty much
my mom's like dude what's this beard
style you did you shaved half your beard
i'm like no that's just the grays are
there
and then it's i know have you done the
did you see like little
patterns for me
animals the worst is only one side of my
head is really great and the other one's
kind of normal so it's just you have
like
i got gray nose hairs now oh yeah i'm
starting to get those dudes thank god
for manscapes
without that weed whacker dude i don't
know what i would do oh man
all right hey dude let's go check out
the wrestling ring and
check out the wrestling ring we did
he dove off one corner while i did a
back flip
over him from the other corner
pretty psyched on that and the guy's
like
a little kid man he got in his wrestling
where he was just
so excited and bouncing off the ropes
they were just running around
like dude this is i really fell in love
with him man
and i fell in love with you guys a long
time ago those of you who stick around
to the very
end and especially the ones who stick
around to the very end
and then take a screenshot of the
podcast anywhere and then you take that
screenshot and you post it
so that you can tag me and so that you
can tag the guest david arquette to let
them know
what a what a great podcast that was how
much you enjoyed it and i
do encourage you to check out his
documentary it's called
you cannot kill david arquette and it
really really
i loved it i absolutely loved the doc i
loved the guy
and i love you yeah dude